يمثلون وقناصره من دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه
ودول الاخرى اليوم زياره الى المسجد
الاقصى المبارك ومن المقرر ان يلتقي الوفد
الاوروبي مسؤولين في دائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه تهدف الزياره الى التاكيد على
موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان ضروره الحفاظ
على الوضع القانوني والتاريخي القائم في
المسجد الاقصى
ويزوروا اسرائيل وفد من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي مكونا مما يعرف بتجمع اتفاقات
ابرهم في مجلس الشيوخ وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وامريكيه افادت بان رئيسه
الوفد السناتور جاكيروزن طلبت عدم ادراك
ممثلين عن حزب العظمه اليهوديه وحزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه اللذين يتراسهما كل من
من كثير وساموت ريتش خلال اجتماعات الوفي
باسرائيل
للمتابعه ينضم الي من باب الاسباط في
القدس تنضمي اليه مراسلته والجزيره نجوان
سمري مرحبا نجوان انت موجوده اذا مع الوقت
الذي يبدا فيه
اعضاء من الاتحاد الاوروبي القناصل
والممثلون هذه هي الزياره المسجد الاقصى
المبارك التفاصيل من عندك
صباح الخير محمد يصل في هذه اللحظات الى
باب الاسباط
المدخلي المسجد الاقصى المبارك عده ممثلين
من
الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وقناه من الاتحاد
الاوروبي يصلون في هذه الزياره الى المسجد
الاقصى المباركيه الزياره الاولى في فتره
هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده المتشدده
هدف هذه الزياره اولا الالتقاء ب- همم
مسؤولين في دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه نرى
هنا يستقبلهم الشيخ عزام الخطيب مدير
الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس نحو 25 من
القناسل والممثلين يصلون في هذه الزياره
ناره هنا استنفار لقوات شرطه الاحتلال عند
باب الاسباط ومن الواضح ان هناك تعزيزات
امنيه بحسب مصادر في الاتحاد الاوروبي فان
هذه الزياره تاتي للتاكيد على موقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي من ضرورات الحفاظ على
الوضع القانوني وتاريخي القائم في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك واحترام الوصايه الاردنيه
على الاوقاف الاسلاميه والمقدسات في مدينه
القدس وايضا رساله اخرى هي تفادي اي اعمال
من شانها ان تؤجج الاوضاع وتصاعد في
الموقف في مدينه القدس وسائر الاراضي
الفلسطينيه همم نرى بان هذا الوفد يدخل في
هذه الاثناء ويستقبله مسؤولون في دائره
الاوقاف الاسلاميه والاردنيه في داخل
المسجد الاقصى المبارك سيكون هناك لقاءات
داخل المكتبه القائمه في رحاب همم المسجد
الاقصى نحن نتحدث عن زياره تاتي تماما بعد
يوم واحد على اعتراض عرقله ومنع السفير
الاردني يوم امس من الدخول عبر هذا الباب
الى داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك بحجه عدم
وجود تنسيق مع جهات الاحتلال ايضا مصادر
في الاتحاد الاوروبي هنا سمعنا بانه كان
هناك يوم امس عده ضغوطات فقط محمد
ضغوطات على رئيس الوفد في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
لتغييرات في الاجراءات المتبعه والتنسيق
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي لكن الاتحاد
الاوروبي رفض ذلك وقام بهذه الزياره
بالترتيب مع الاوقاف الاسلاميه كما كان
متبعا ضمن الوضع القانوني وتاريخ القائم
محمد نعم اسمعك نعم تحدثت عن نقطه ان هذه
الزياره تاتي بعد ما حدث لسفير الاردني
همم هل تقرر القيام بهذه الزياره مباشره
تردد فعل
ما وقع او كان مخططا لهذه الزياره التي
يقوم بها في هذه الاثناء همم ممثلون
وقناصله عن الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول الاخرى
بالتاكيد
الزياره كانت مخططه قبل الحادثه يوم امس
ولكنها خططت بعد اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
تمار بين كبير رئيس حزب عظمه يهوديه الذي
اقتحم المسجد الاقصى قبل نحو اسبوعين من
الان وكانت هناك ردود فعل همم انتقاديه
واسعه سواء كانت محليه او دوليه على هذا
الاقتحام الذي قام به به بنك قبل اسبوعين
وايضا من الاتحاد الاوروبي كان هناك همم
موقف وبيان انتقد هذه الزياره او هذا
الاقتحام لبن كبير وقال بانه يجب الحفاظ
على الوضع القانوني القائم في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وعدم القيام باي خطوات او
افعال من شانها ان تؤجج الاوضاع في المسجد
او في القدس او في سائر الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هذه الزياده تاتي في سياق هذا
الاقتحام لبنك كبير وكما ذكرت حتى في
اللحظات الاخيره الليله الماضيه كانت هناك
ومحاولات من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي وشرطه
الاحتلال لاجراء التغييرات في اليه دخول
هذا الوفد الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك حتى
انه كان يفترض ان يعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا بعد
هذه الزياره على ما يبدو سيتم الغاء هذا
المؤتمر بفعل الضغوطات لكن اصر الوفد
الاوروبي ان يدخل بالتنسيق مع دائره
الاوقاف الاسلاميه والاردنيه في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك دون اي تنسيق مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي كما كان متبعا في السابق
بطبيعه الحالتين الوقت هناك محاولات من
قبل سلطات الاحتلال والان تحديدا متمثله
بوزير الامن القومي المتطرف في تمر بني
كبير بما يسمونه فرد السياسه السياسه اكثر
واكثر على المسجد الاقصى المبارك ادق
التفاصيل تحاول اسرائيل دائما التحكم
بمفاصل هذه الامور بكل من يدخل كل ما يدخل
الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك وهذا يؤدي الى
توترات كبيره في العلاقات بين الجانب
الاردني والجانب الاسرائيلي بسبب
المحاولات الاسرائيليه الدائمه للمساس
بمكانه الاردن في وصايتها ورعايتها
للمقدسات وللمسجد الاقصى في القدس هذا ما
حدث يوم امس مع السفير الاردني هذا ما
يسعى اليه بينجو دائما الى ان التنسيق بكل
ما يتعلق بالمسجد الاقصى المبارك ان يتم
معه مباشره مع وزارته ومع شرطه الاحتلال
نجوان سمري من امام باب الاسباط في القدس
هي المحتله شكرا جزيلا لك